[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine football l'as saint
gobain football cup était organisé ce
week-end à clairefontaine l'événement a
réuni 24 équipes de commerce et
d'ingénieurs venus de toute la france au
portage dans ce magazine football
toujours le footballeur elvinois
aurélien collin a décidé de prendre sa
retraite sportive après 11 années dans
le championnat américain nous l'avons
rencontré il reviendra notamment sur son
parcours en mls enfin un coup de
projecteur sur le club de football de ou
une structure qui compte près de mille
trois cents licenciés et une équipe qui
évolue dans le championnat de régionale
2 chiens l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
on va tout de suite prendre la direction
de clairefontaine ce week-end le site a
accueilli la 10e édition de la saint
gobain aac football cup abordez-vous qui
a réuni à 24 équipes des écoles
d'ingénieurs de commerce de toute la
france zoom sur cette compétition des
images de bixente mais rien senti steban
j'ai demandé à camille sur le corner vu
qu'elle est prise par l de partir
premier poteau et charlotte on les tire
au deuxième round 12e à personne
l'équipe d' hec paris ne laisse rien au
hasard ce samedi 23 avril ses joueuses
voulant remporter la saint gobain
football cup un rendez-vous qui oppose
les écoles d'ingénieurs et de commerce
de toute la france pour cela elle
s'entraîne trois fois par semaine depuis
plusieurs mois ce jour-là à
clairefontaine c'est le jour de vérité
là on est surexcité
et on y perd ferrari perd contente il ya
aussi un bon esprit qu'on fait quand
même entre les écoles on est là pour
défendre notre école vraiment quoi mais
on s'amuse bien entre nous il ya un bon
esprit qui règne dans le tournoi cette
équipe basée à jouy en josas fait partie
des 24 écoles présentes ce week end dans
les îles ville à l'occasion de cette
coupe de france étudiante depuis dix ans
l'événement réunit chaque année
plusieurs milliers de joueurs de
l'hexagone en soit ces maillots à ses
couleurs on a son nom dessus on est aidé
pour les déplacements la réservation des
terrains et bien entendu graal final il
est de venir ici pendant trois jours
disputer les phases finales de chaque
coupe de france et celle des écoles de
commerce elle des ingénieurs en
parallèle de la compétition l'événement
se veut également professionnel avec
l'entreprise sponsor de l'événement
venus dénicher les futurs talents on les
observe pas directement sur le terrain
c'est plus de les changes qui se passe
en bord de terrain on va comprendre un
peu leur projet professionnel leur
expliquer les métiers qu'on peut avoir
au sein du groupe nous on a pas mal
d'offres à pourvoir on a en tout ou à
peu près de 1500 offre de stage
alternance cdi et donc bah voilà essayer
de trouver le bon match sur le terrain
après trois jours de compétition
l'équipe féminine d' hec s'est imposé
dans sa catégorie face à l'edhec lille
en finale au total quatre équipes sont
qualifiées pour la grande finale de la
saint gobain football cup elles
s'affronteront en fin d'année
on va maintenant passer aux trois
résultats retenir dans les yvelines en
golf antoine or other termine à une très
belle 5e place sur lies ps en date
championship sur le dpw tour à tarragone
rendez-vous remportée par l'espagnol
pablo larrazabal son premier top 5
depuis à cinq mois en football dans le
championnat de nationale 2 ça se
rapproche pour versailles les versailles
et se sont imposés 3 0 à domicile sur le
terrain de la réserve de caen l'occasion
de la 26e journée dans le même temps le
voisin pisciacais a tenu en échec ses
sharks sur son terrain le principal
rival de versailles dans la course à la
montée au classement les joueurs de la
cité royale sont premiers avec neuf
points d'avancé sur chartres poissy et
9e du classement en baseball carton
plein ce week-end pour les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux lors de la 3e
journée il y monte 1 se sont imposés
deux fois ce dimanche sur le terrain du
puck de paris avec des scores sans appel
8 1 dans le premier match et 11 1 dans
la seconde partie ces résultats
permettent à montigny le bretonneux de
prendre la première place de la poule
avec un bilan de 3 victoires pour une
défaite en tennis les viennois arthur
rinderknecht n'a pas participé au
tournoi atp 500 de barcelone la semaine
dernière le joueur originaire de saint
germain en laye a déclaré forfait en
raison d'une blessure au poignet droit
un nouveau coup dur pour le 57e joueur
mondial à l'open d'australie en début de
saison il avait déjà dû déclarer forfait
en raison d'une douleur au même endroit
il espère maintenant pouvoir récupérer
en vue de roland garros le tournoi
débutera fin mai du côté de la porte
d'auteuil en boxe libye noise maiva
hamadouche n'arrêtera finalement pas sa
carrière la boxeuse avait pourtant
annoncé cette décision sur les réseaux
sociaux après l'annulation de son combat
programmé à dubaï en mai prochain face à
l'aube est à la belle job delphine à
personne
la sportive de 32 ans avait écrit
mercredi dernier j'arrête ma carrière
j'ai fait de belles choses des propos
supprimer quelques instants plus tard
deux joints par téléphone son agent a
bien confirmé que maiva hamadouche
allait continuer à boxer a malgré ce
coup de sang sur les réseaux sociaux la
sportive entraînée par la team farrugia
il en quoi avant les jo de tokyo attend
désormais un nouveau challenger c'est
une légende de la mls qui raccroche les
crampons aurélien collin originaire de
fontenay le fleury a décidé de prendre
sa retraite à l'âge de 36 ans le
défenseur notamment gagné le championnat
américain la major league soccer et à
jouer avec des joueurs internationaux
comme sir henry ou kaka on les écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est bon moment après
beaucoup d'années c'est le temps de
garder mais mes crampons et de me
concentrer sur une nouvelle page des
trois dernières années j'ai beaucoup
moins joué j'étais beaucoup plus
concentrés sur le sueur et desservir
former la jeunesse dans mon club à
chelsea c'était vraiment la philosophie
c'était aider les jeunes à jouer et à
être performant et et après aller vendre
dans des bons clubs en europe en
amérique centrale et du sud et j'ai aidé
mon club faire ça et donc petit à petit
je me rapprochais du monde d'entraîneur
et je m'éloigne du monde des joueurs est
donc là maintenant j'ai pris ma retraite
comme toujours ma finale en 2013 et
on a gagné on a été champions et ça a
été le haut de
pic de ma carrière en 2013 mais on a
gagné on a été champion des états unis
et de donner ça une équipe comme kansas
city qui était à l'époque une petite
équipe n'a vraiment changé la perception
des gens sur le kansas
aux etats unis toutes les équipes
championnes elles vont à la maison
blanche n'a eu la privilège de
rencontrer obama et ils voient la
machine petit une petite vanne après ça
montre déjà été nommé fin 2014 ça
restera aussi dans ma mémoire c'était
quoi la petite veine moi c'était par
rapport à la manière avec laquelle
j'étais habillé à l'époque j'avais les
magasins de vêtements et
et j'avais une foulards et des boucles
d'oreilles il a dit aux accueils ils
veulent me ressembler quand il sortira
de qu'on sortira de l'office de la
maison blanche
thierry henry ça a été un grand exemple
je ne connaissais pas du tout et grâce à
la mls j'ai pu rencontrer et le
connaître et c'est un joueur très
professionnel amoureux du football
grâce à l'est mais j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance de côtoyer des grands joueurs qui
même par leur comportement comme kaka
sans lien direct ils te poussent vers le
haut d'avoir eu la chance de pouvoir
côtoyer des joueurs aussi bons ça ça te
fait que grandir footballistiquement et
aussi commandes et par ce qu'ils ont
vécu des expériences énorme
[Musique]
aux etats unis c'est accepter qu'on peut
aller jusqu'à 99 donc directement je
suis arrivé à qantas tige est demandée
78 ha je suis né et j'ai grandi à
fontenay le fleury et bien sûr c'est une
fierté et j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup
de d'être personne du 120 118 qui
pourront voyager autant et voir autant
de deux cultures
[Musique]
je reviens je rentre en europe ce que je
fais entre paris et madrid c'est pour me
former en tant qu'entraîneur et
directeur
national directeur général comme on dit
là-bas manager général et donc ça se
rentre madrid paris et manchester je
veux vraiment étudié pour être
très con les bonnes opportunités
montagne
[Musique]
on va maintenant passer notre module
sport va continuer à parler à football
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur le
oui athletic club une structure créée en
1913 et qui compte aujourd'hui plus de
1300 licencié à regarder la séquence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui pour ce mode le sport nous
sommes à houilles pour découvrir ce club
de football ac partie
[Musique]
pour nous présenter ce club de où je
suis avec le président à xavier blot
alors xavier qu'est l'histoire de ce
club de houille très bien aux clubs
français créée en 1913 les initiales où
il était dix clubs reprenait évidemment
les initiales du havre athletic club
doyen des clubs français le créateur est
mort immédiatement pour la première
mondiale une ou plusieurs présidents qui
se sont succédé c'est un club très connu
au début de la même guerre mondiale qui
a atteint les huitièmes de faire la
coupe de france de la zone occupée le
clab à végéter ensuite jusqu'aux années
80 mon prédécesseur
là à redorer son blason en créant
notamment mouthe équipes de jeunes et
malheureusement mon prédécesseur est
mort sur le terrain lors d'un match
vétérans c'est une tragédie pour le club
lequel a été six mois sans président
j'utilise moi même entraîneur et j'avais
terminé ma carrière et du courant m'a
demandé de faire le saut j'ai donc été
élu en avril 2001 et aujourd'hui le club
en est où le club aujourd'hui quand
mille trois cent cinquante adhérents
c'est une grosse machinerie nous sommes
traditionnellement depuis cinq ans dans
les cinq premiers clubs français
nous sommes la lutte avec deux clubs
franciliens est généralement le club du
sc lyon vient s'intercaler également
parmi les premiers clubs au nombre de
licenciés nous avons quatre équipes par
ligne d'âge par catégorie donc ce soit
une fugue 10 etc jusqu'à u18 et en
seniors nous sommes à trois équipes et
deux équipes en vétérans nous profitons
de ville extrêmement jeune au niveau des
parents ou une carrière besançon entre
800 les huîtres additionnant jeunes ont
beaucoup de couples vont travailler à la
défense landais et sociétés d'assurance
les banques et de fait nous avons
énormément de petit puisque nous sommes
à des clubs en france a le plus de
débutants nous avons 2 185 licenciés de
rue89 et environ 250 présents tous les
mardis soir de quoi vous êtes le plus
fier vous en tant que président c'était
certainement garder un esprit convivial
malgré la masse ça toujours été un gros
problème on a remarqué que les clubs qui
ont grandi c'est oublié par favorable
nous avons eu ici pour l'instant avec
plusieurs petites astuces à garder cet
esprit familial les astuces qui
consistent à leurs parents en entraîneur
de jeunes les dimanches des entraves qui
participe aussi à l'école de foot le
samedi tous nos entraîneurs en deux
participations ainsi l'entraîneur des u
16 ans traîne 2012 ainsi en train de 14
ans traîne et lyon et s'est même eu deux
vies gauthier entre la première
intervient en débutant mardi soir et
nous avons également été un des premiers
clubs franciliens a instauré une buvette
foyer ouvert tous les jours 7 sur 7 avec
tes une en ligne en amplitude horaire ce
qui permet aux gens de se retrouver
également être converser nous pensons
également aux parents quand il fait
froid l'hiver donc ça a été un travail
de très longue haleine pour garder cette
âme malgré la masse puisque nous sommes
passés de 250 que j'ai pris la
présidence à 1350 points vous l'avez
évoqué la coupe de france c'est aussi
l'une des spécificités peut-être du club
il ya souvent des beaux parcours en
coupe de france en tout à fait donc je
vous ai parlé du parcours en 39 40 nous
avons remis à la mode il ya maintenant
cinq ans en atteignant d'abord un
sixième tour puis un septième et enfin
il ya trois ans la possibilité de sortir
jusqu'en 32e de finale avec un tirage un
petit peu inattendu puisque nous étions
dans le groupe nord auprès tirage nous
sommes retrouvés reçoit un club des dom
tom
c'est une aventure qui fédère ici un
très gros potentiel public nous allions
était 17e tour le premier club en nombre
des spectateurs 1 32e nous allons était
le second de tous les 32e de finale nous
pouvons ici sans problème passer de 2000
à 3000 spectateurs pour un match de
coupe de france c'est assez rare en foot
amateur l'équipe une qui joue
actuellement en régionale 2
a le potentiel d'aller en régionale une
elle a tout à fait le potentiel et le
projet est celui-là l'année dernière
nous en avons été empêchés par la
commune nous étions déjà en tête au
moment de l'arrêt des compétitions nous
sommes à la lutte avec un club très
sérieux bobby autrement appelée fc 93
qui est un club qui a environ 30 joueurs
de niveau national de cap très sérieux
qui est troisième en une deux dans
l'équipe première qui est actuellement
premier avec deux points d'avancé en r2
ce n'est pas une surprise donc à ce
niveau là c'est pas ton labeur
l'effectif qui composent le groupe nous
avons une très bonne équipe c'est le
fait de se voir se retrouver qu'un autre
club qui est également très fort nous
allons justement maintenant rencontrer
cette équipe qui joue en régionale 2
chiens
[Musique]
pour nous parler de cette équipe senior
je suis aux côtés de ludovic gauthier à
le coach depuis deux ans et demi alors
lui de vie comment ça se passe cette
saison 2021 2022 bon la saison elle
avait très bien commencé voilà on avait
fait une belle série de victoires 6
matches en sept matchs avec un match nul
et là on est dans une passe un peu plus
difficile où on vient de concéder
malheureusement deux défaites de suite
dont une contre nos deux concurrents
directs donc voila tout reste à jouer on
est aujourd'hui deuxième avec un point
de retard suite à ses mauvais résultats
mais voilà on s'accroche est ce que ce
groupe a de la qualité ludovic ce groupe
il a énormément de qualités
c'est l'un des meilleurs groupes que
j'ai entraînés au niveau qualité si ce
n'est le meilleur
le président m'a fait confiance dans le
recrutement des joueurs donc beaucoup de
gens aux gens le projet de houille qui
monte au réal et moi j'ai la
responsabilité des résultats
donc on s'accroche mais vraiment le
groupe est de qualité il ya des bons
garçons on est touché un peu mollement
avec ses contre-performances mais on a
la qualité pour rebondir et on va on va
réaliser nos objectifs j'ai confiance en
eux j'ai confiance en moi c'est ça le
plus important après je détiens pas la
vérité du foot mais on va tout faire
pour réaliser les objectifs du club et
est en fait moi j'ai envie de donner
rendre la confiance que le président a
donné donc ça me tient à coeur de de
réaliser ses objectifs
quel est votre style de jeu à l'iddri
gauthier pas moi j'aime que mon équipe
produisent un beau football
voilà qu'on puisse avoir le ballon qu'on
puisse conserver ce ballon progresser
finir les actions et aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que on joue sur des terrains
difficiles et ça voilà ça nous aide pas
mais on doit être capable de s'adapter
au terrain et l'inde doit être capable
de montrer autre chose que ce que
montrent ces dernières semaines oui les
terrains sont pas bons mais voilà notre
déception de jeu sur un mauvais terrain
il faut qu'on passe au dessus pour
vraiment voilà passer au dessus de ça et
pas se plaindre des terrains le terrain
c'est le même pour les deux équipes même
si c'est un avantage ou ça nivelle les
valeurs selon le terrain voilà c'est
nous notre objectif c'est de gagner des
matches bien jouer au football et on
essaye de s'y attacher on se prépare à
bien la semaine oui les spécialistes le
disent en vous jouer quand même plutôt
bien en football vous essayez produire
du jour vous n'aimez pas trop subir par
contre comme toute équipe on veut plutôt
attaquer que défendre l'objectif du foot
c'est de mettre un but de plus que
l'adversaire ça va parce qu'on n'entend
pas qu'on va gagner le match mais par
contre sur la marque plus que
l'adversaire on va le gagner donc notre
objectif c'est d'attaquer ces d'avant le
ballon quand on n'a pas le ballon c'est
comment le récupérer comment s'organiser
mais le voilà on s'y attache alors oui
il ya deux petite contre-performance
mais mais voilà c'est pas fini il y a
beaucoup de jeunes dans ce club on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure et que le
président est-ce que c'est aussi votre
rôle à vous de les incorporer dans cette
équipe première oui avec le président
qui suit beaucoup la catégorie u18
énormément toutes les autres catégories
mais le dimanche comme jour lever de
rideau de l'équipe seniors c c'est plus
facile donc il me fait des retours moi
quand je suis là j'arrive à les observer
comme il joue sur ce même terrain est le
nôtre il ya des joueurs qui viennent
avec nous la semaine à l'entraînement et
même sur des matches amicaux j'ai déjà
pris des u18 du club donc non non c'est
important c'est l'avenir de ces voix là
c'est le feu l'affût le futur de
l'équipe première de deux où ils les
jeunes du club ce soir u12 u13 ouais
c'est pour ça qu'on tour se doit de
monter pour évoluer un bon niveau et
pour que les jeunes puissent évoluer
dans l'équipe fanion du câble c'est
l'objectif c'est mon objectif de les
incorporer de les suivre d'échangés
énormément et éducateurs des 18 c'est ce
qu'on fait voilà aussi sur un peu dans
la difficulté en ce moment au niveau des
résultats mais mais voilà on essaye de
bien travailler après le foot sert pas
de science infuse ce qui est important
c'est de bien travailler ne pas avoir de
regrets à la fin de la saison dernière
question ludovic gauthier quel est votre
plus grand rêve est avec ce club
c'est pas un rêve parce que derrière
voilà mais l'objectif ce serait de
monter en rien d'être renouvelée par le
président de monter en nationale 3 le
projet et sur le long terme mais il est
sur le long terme mais aussi sur le
court terme les résultats faut qu'ils
arrivent maintenant voilà il ya des
années qu'ovide malheureusement avant ça
fait perdre du retard sur sur nos
échéances mais maintenant que la saison
va aller à son terme il faut qu'on soit
dans l'objectif c'est ça le plus
important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis maintenant aux côtés de deux
joueurs du club harnes eti et zakaria
alors à kariat pourquoi tu as choisi ce
que douilles alors j'ai choisi ce club
parce que tout d'abord j'habite juste à
côté c'est vrai que c'est un club que je
connais depuis depuis très longtemps
maintenant un club avec de l'ambition
qui a gravi les échelons année après
année et voilà j'arrive à un moment de
ma carrière ou professionnellement et
d'un point de vue personnel avec ma
famille qui s'est agrandie j'avais plus
forcément le temps d'aller très loin
comme un versailles auparavant et voilà
c'est un choix un choix du coeur un peu
parce que c'est c'est des gens que je
connais depuis longtemps et c'est un
club avec de l'ambition donc voilà tout
était réuni pour que je vienne enfin oui
ça fait 2 ans et 5 t/ha où il ya deux
ans exactement deux ans arletty alors
toi tu es arrivé aussi il ya deux ans
pourquoi alors tout simplement parce que
moi précédemment gt gt aux mureaux
j'étais en nationale 3 et ça me plaisait
pas trop tout simplement et
j'ai choisi de rejoindre mon ancien
coach ludovic gauthier avec avec lequel
ça se passait très bien versailles donc
du coup jeudi suivis ici ah oui avec un
très beau coup de des potes que je
connais très très bien donc voilà
pourquoi j'ai décidé tout simplement de
devenir et ce qu'est ce que tu penses
toi de ce club c'est un club assez
familial quand même avec me emile 300
licenciés mais quand même un club assez
familial exactement
les parents des joueurs viennent rien
assez souvent voir les matchs donc les
enfants viennent aussi exactement et il
ya bien un club house qui propose à ses
beaucoup de choses
donc
moi ici je me semble à sa carrière un
club familial 1 c'est bien ça ouais
honnêtement comme à diane étions si ça
très bien on est très bien entouré tout
le monde se plie en quatre pour nous
c'est un gros club avec beaucoup de
licenciés donc je passe un club qui a de
l'avenir encore une fois et voilà
l'image de notre de notre coach adjoint
alain plus connu sous le nom de chipeau
c'est quelqu'un qui fait tout pour
nouveau nettement il nous met dans les
meilleures dispositions donc on n'a pas
à se plaindre en tant que joueur même
plus haut pour avoir connu un niveau
plus élevé on retrouve pas forcément
c'est cet encadrement et ce dévouement
de tous les gens qui nous accompagnent
franchement on est dans les meilleures
dispositions cette équipe de régionale 2
allée comment a competitive oui très
très compétitive il ya beaucoup de
niveaux il ya beaucoup de joueurs qui
viennent du dessus donc c'est une équipe
vraiment avec un très très bon niveau et
très compétitive et c'est une équipe
également qu'il ya de grandes ambitions
cette année vous êtes actuellement
deuxièmes mais ou viser la première
place exactement donc la très récemment
ont malheureusement on a perdu la
première place à cause de deux défaites
de suite mais on vous lâche pas
simplement parce que voilà on est
déterminés à accéder aux régionales 1
qui
qui est notre ambition là en court terme
après on a plutôt l'ambition de de
gravir les échelons jusqu'à en nationale
3 et pourquoi pas au-delà donc on met
tout ce qu'il faut pour et puis on va
pas lâcher jusqu'à la fin de la saison
cette équipe a le mérite la régionale
une saga je le pense honnêtement je le
pense sur ce qu'on a montré depuis deux
ans maintenant parce que voilà l'année
dernière comme tout le monde le sait ça
a été une année un peu spécial on a fait
beaucoup d'efforts cette année et on va
pas lâcher jusqu'au bout on est dans le
sprint final et j'espère qu'on sera
récompensé de tous les efforts qu'on a
pu faire votre plus grand rêve avec ce
club de oui ce sera ma dernière question
accéder au national troyes ce serait
bien finir là où j'ai joué longtemps ce
serait ce serait franchement un vrai
plaisir de finir à ce niveau-là
réalisable je pense je pense maintenant
je pense
ski qui commencent à avancer donc faut
que je me dépêche faucon faut pas qu'on
tarde à monter ahmeti alors
personnellement mon plus grand rêve avec
club de oui c'est pareil de toujours en
nationale 3 c'est comme
comme sa cage et puis jouer en nationale
3 et c'est un très très bon niveau et ce
club de où il mérite vraiment mérite
vraiment d'y accéder avec tous les
moyens qui qui sont mis pour mais ça
ferait plaisir au coach et sur le
plaisir à principaux comme comme appui
de gensac à
plus de 1300 à licencier une équipe en
régionale 2 qui pourrait monter dans les
prochaines années en régionale une où il
définitivement l'une des équipes de
football les plus excitantes de france
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
on